Ray Romano is joining us he's performing
in Las Vegas at the Mirage with David
Spade coming up February 23rd and 24th
also season two of get shorty for epochs
Everybody Loves Raymond the big sick big
sick was great it really there was there
was a lot of fun with that and I don't
know how complex that role was because
it wasn't the typical Ray's gonna be the
funniest guy in the room no no it was a
look they sent me the script and it was
written by Kumail who I'd never know I
never heard of him and Mike I brought
the script home and my kids who are much
hipper and with it than me they said no
dad you got to do this this this guy is
cool and then Holly Hunter was gonna be
my wife and it was kind of a no-brainer
but I never thought what how well it's
been received I didn't never thought
this you know they were nominated for an
Oscar yeah yeah yeah no and it's it's
based on his life and I met his wife
they were flying to New York to do
Saturday Night Live and so I got a
chance like oh yeah yeah yeah it was
great yeah it's funny cuz Emily you know
it's based on their life so I played her
father and Holly Hunter plays her mother
and she told us that when when she
showed her parents the the movie the
mother said you know Holly is is
better-looking than me but your father's
better-looking yeah that stays with me
when did you know you were funny what
time is it you know like what age I
don't want to use the tip I'm gonna give
you the typical answers for communities
you doubt it all the time you know you
don't know I just know I liked comedy
and I was I was drawn to comedy I was a
fan of stand-up Saturday when Saturday
Night Live came out I was 17 and
everybody these guys in the neighborhood
that I hung out with we were so into it
that we did that we put on a talent show
for our neighborhood crowd it was called
no talents incorporated yet so I was
always a fan of comedy and it was until
I got on the stage the first time in New
York that I got the
the bug of performing of stand-up and it
never went away and it still doesn't I
mean stand up is still I love doing the
acting and everything is is what I'm
doing now it's what gets me up and went
but in my core I feel that's what I do
I'm a stand-up and acting is one of the
perks do you remember one of the jokes
from your first standup
I remember a bunch of them and I will
never say them here what wait because
you can't one I can't - it's horrible
horrible
I do remember yeah oh yeah I even this
one I want to say probably I shouldn't
but again this was go ahead fire 25
years ago when I was young and stupid
and it was making fun of the written
exam for your driver's license they're
written how easy it is this is the first
time I'm on stage so you got a mark on a
curve here but I said they have to make
the the permit test they have to make
that harder you know it's like a blind
person is crossing the road you should a
let him go by B stop and see if he wants
to continue to cross or C nudge him a
little so he knows you're there alright
and and that stayed in my act for about
six months after that yeah then there
are ones that are just I can't even
believe I did those those jokes on stage
you know they're just so wrong yeah and
unfunny - who's the the comedian that
you you saw and you went I don't know if
I can I don't know if I can do this if
I'm compared to that well I mean Robert
Klein and George Carlin and and as far
as not as household name Larry Miller uh
no Larry Miller yeah I would watch Larry
Miller and just his his style the way he
would just converse and and he didn't
have to yell and scream and
and it's so subtle yet so sharp
Letterman loved heavenly honor yeah yeah
we always took care of those those old
older comedians maybe less known
comedians there yes yes yes he did
remember your Royal Letterman appearance
I do I I do remember it because I'm not
sitting here without it because I had
been doing stand-up for 11 years and I
had done mostly every show a stand-up
could do except Letterman and I was
still just a working comic which was
fine with me
but I just thought if I'm ever gonna
jump to the next level it should have
happened by now because everybody was
getting development deals or shows and
it was my first Letterman that where
that happened when I when I finished my
Letterman I knew it went well even for
myself I'm very pessimistic and and and
the glass is half-empty but I knew I had
a good set and the week later they
called my house on a Saturday I remember
this exactly I'm pulling on a Saturday
afternoon they called my house in Queens
Rob Burnett who was the producer and he
said hey just want you to know that
they've loved it and we're interested in
signing you for a development deal we
want to talk about it so if anyone else
offers please come out so I went and
there's nobody I'll sign over the phone
if I have to and he produced Everybody
Loves Raymond that's how everybody can
amazing yeah yeah that was and that was
I done 30 about 35 Letterman's so since
that one you know I did I did like two a
year while the show was on and then one
after you know Letterman's my guy yeah
when did you know that Everybody Loves
Raymond was gonna be something different
um it's funny because in about about the
sixth episode here it was the thing
about the show is nobody knows who I am
nobody knows the show so to get an
audience to come in a live audience in
the studio this is gonna sound like it's
a it's a joke but it isn't they would
bust people in from senior citizen
bones I'm not kidding and rehab
facilities yes
and that's your demo that's who they put
for the live audience they had to fill
the audience and sometimes it would pay
you would get paid sometimes to be an
audience member so the first so we're
writing bit we're writing material and
it's not setup punchline setup punchline
it's character based so when Doris
Roberts walks in the room and and you
know that sparks are gonna fly they
don't know that because they don't know
the characters yet so the first couple
episodes it was pretty weak with that
studio studio audience you know we just
had to believe that the material was was
good enough and then about the and then
when it aired about six episodes we
filmed six episodes before the first one
aired and then like about the second or
third or fourth episode after that the
people coming in the studio audience
were now aware of these characters and
knew them and it was about then where we
we could feel there was a chemistry
going on you know and bred you know Brad
Garrett it was very lucky because it was
based on my life but Brad Brad Garrett
plays my brother and my brother is five
foot ten Brad Garrett six foot eight you
know Brad Garrett brings this whole
hangdog thing to it that wasn't on the
paper and that's the thing you get
that's the magic you gotta have you
gotta get lucky like that yeah Brett
he's six foot eight and he's Jewish by
the way which is the world's record I
think you can cut that right no no I'll
leave it in Ray Romano joining us he'll
be at the Mirage with David Spade
February 23rd in twenty-fourth you get
mistaken for anybody I get mistaken
sometimes for a very old Zach Braff you
know Zach Braff yes okay I could see
that how about a younger Pacino you know
no one's ever mistaken me for him of
course but can i I don't want a name
drop can I tell a little al pacino story
fire away because I just got we just
wrapped I got cast in the Irishman which
Scorsese's doing about Jimmy Hoffa
yeah and Al Pacino is playing Jimmy
Hoffa and I got cast in a
all role by play his lawyer I don't know
how it happened but anyway we're sitting
there and I never met Al Pacino so now
it's like this third day of shooting and
so to age me up for them they're gonna
CGI they're gonna CGI it's it's it's the
Niro Pacino and Pesci and they're gonna
CGI them it to look like 40-year old you
know young men and for me they're just
gonna age me with makeup and a fat suit
they put a fat suit on me for when I'm
like 70 not big but just like a pouch
and we had just eaten lunch and we were
sitting down ready to do the next scene
so I'm sitting and Al Pacino's over
there and he's dead serious he he looks
at me he goes you're wearing the fat
suit for this scene I said no no I'm not
I was wearing it's kinda it's not as bad
as telling or asking a woman when she's
do yes he's not but it's in the ballpark
I've done that yeah you've got done that
I think I did it once yeah I did it once
and I never ever you know even even if
we have a friend who works with us and
Calleigh is ready to deliver at any
moment I don't still don't even ask
about her being pregnant now I get his
yeah she's in the back here yeah I don't
even ask oh you're not pregnant okay but
that's got to be pretty intimidating you
see you got De Niro Pacino Pesci yeah it
was it's crazy it's surreal it's but did
you ever think your acting ability would
be something I still don't I still feel
like what am I doing here you know the
reason I got it was cuz on vinyl
Scorsese directed the pilot vinyl and
there was a role available that my agent
submitted before so they said send in
the tape put yourself on tape doing the
van and Marty will look at it so I did
it I sent in a tape and the the feedback
was Marty likes what he did and he wants
to know who he is he's never heard of
him before he had never seen me before
on anything which I'm not gonna be so
you know pompous to think how could he
not see me because he doesn't watch TV
you know he's a genius he's a movie
genius
but that worked in my favor he had know
everybody loves raymond you know he
didn't see that character and he yeah
and that's the and so i got that role
and then for this one I didn't have to
audition he just cast me as as the
lawyer but I was petrified because I
knew he saw me in vinyl he saw what I
could do and that's what he cares and
this one he's just thinking Oh Ray's way
can do this and but he didn't see me do
it so I all the time I'm like I got
nervous I got broke out I got I don't
know if you can get eczema of that way
but I think I did I'm not kidding it was
like what your greatest golf moment you
got one greatest golf moment uh well
making the cut here is pretty big yeah
you know I played thirteen years before
making the cut here and people don't
know how much we're grinding it out you
know I'm here to the people aren't here
to see me golf they're here to maybe I'd
say a joke here there I even smile and
you know so you hit a bad shot and and
you're dying inside but you got a smile
yeah what when I stand over a ball I
have to have two thoughts I have to have
a swing for it and a joke thought for
when it's done yes but making the cut
here was great
oh it's tougher though you know
recovering from the bad shot or
recovering from a bad joke uh well it
happens a lot in both of them I mean you
know I make a living telling jokes so if
you know if one's bad that's fine
recovering from a bad shot here is is
hard because I'm not kidding where's my
caddie my caddie is my best friend
Claude from from Queens New York
I fly him out every year and this is the
week of our life yeah and by the way if
you're gonna have a caddy don't have
your best friend from Queens because
he's not the cheerleader he's not the
guy you know he yes that he said
yesterday we were waiting to hit and I
said to him you know we waiting there
people up by the green and I said do you
think I can hit now and he said yeah
there's nobody in the water
all day all days like that that's mean
well good luck today ring and say hello
to our good friend David Spade he'll be
at the Mirage February 23rd 24th and
season 2 of get shorty error epochs
thank you for stopping by appreciate it
mono for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience channel 239 on Direct TV or
download the Dan Patrick show app